we have evidence for small-scale
violence like one person hitting another
person but for war between groups the
first evidence we have is from 13
000 years ago which is nothing in
evolutionary terms so all these
arguments that war is part of human
evolution of its inner DNA we have no
evidence for that apparently war is just
a human invention some human cultures
invented this thing of War and the
problem with war is that uh it's
one-sided you know to make peace you
need a lot of people to agree to make
war one person is enough one side is
enough
if uh uh if they decide to have War you
can't just say but we don't agreed
nobody's asking you
so it seems that the history of war is
is a history of it it's it's a human
invention it's not a natural phenomenon
which then spread